Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Lucia: 启动了
Lucia: It's started.
Shure:  面包片对
Shure: The bread slices are...
Shure:  煎的面包片
Shure: The toasted bread slices.
Shure:  杨老板呢
Shure: Where's Jake?
Lucia: 有什么喝的吗
Lucia: Is there anything to drink?
Tasha: 鲜牛奶应该可以吧
Tasha: Fresh milk should be fine, right?
Lucia: 牛奶在那边
Lucia: The milk is over there.
Tasha: 这
Tasha: This...
Tasha: 哎另一个呢
Tasha: Hey, where's the other one?
Lucia: 另一个是用完了吗
Lucia: Is the other one used up?
Katrina:  昨天有买新的吗
Katrina: Did we buy a new one yesterday?
Tasha: 另一瓶喝完了吗
Tasha: Is the other bottle finished?
Lucia: 好像是喝完了
Lucia: Seems like it's finished.
Katrina:  上一次买两瓶
Katrina: We bought two bottles last time.
Katrina:  一瓶已经喝完了
Katrina: One bottle is already gone.
Shure:  杨老板到尝尝面包吧
Shure: Jake, come try the bread.
Shure:  杨老板
Shure: Jake.
Jake: 先对个齐
Jake: First, align it.
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on.
Shure:  面包蘸番茄酱
Shure: Bread dipped in ketchup.
Katrina:  为什么拧不开
Katrina: Why can't I open it?
Tasha: 还有人要喝牛奶吗
Tasha: Anyone else wants milk?
Tasha: 好吧没有
Tasha: Alright, no one?
Lucia: 我可以喝哈哈
Lucia: I can drink it, haha.
Tasha: 算了我看到了
Tasha: Never mind, I see it.
Tasha: 你都已经背叛了
Tasha: You've already betrayed us.
Lucia: 哈哈等我把这这个这个橙汁
Lucia: Haha, let me finish this orange juice...
Lucia: 不是柠檬汁喝完了就喝
Lucia: I mean, lemon juice, then I'll drink it.
Tasha: 黄油少切一点啊
Tasha: Cut a bit less butter.
Tasha: 好没关系
Tasha: It's okay.
Tasha: 你就切吧
Tasha: Just cut it.
Tasha: 这么多可以
Tasha: This much is fine.
Shure:  哈哈放冰箱里
Shure: Haha, put it in the fridge.
Jake: 我吃哪一个呢
Jake: Which one should I eat?
Shure:  你尝个面包吧
Shure: Try the bread.
Shure:  那面包嘎嘎香
Shure: That bread is so fragrant.
Lucia: ah sorry
Lucia: Ah, sorry.
Tasha: 黄油就奶香奶香的了已经
Tasha: The butter is already so creamy.
Shure:  是我碰到的吗
Shure: Was it me who touched it?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Katrina:  不知道
Katrina: I don't know.
Tasha: 看摄像头
Tasha: Check the camera.
Jake: 回头看摄像头
Jake: Look back at the camera.
Shure:  不是这必须调一下VCR我
Shure: No, we need to adjust the VCR.
Shure:  啊这窜下去了是吧
Shure: Ah, it got messed up, right?
Katrina:  把杯子放在这上
Katrina: Put the cup on here.
Jake: 正位数值扫一扫
Jake: Scan the exact value.
Tasha: 天呐摔了几个
Tasha: Oh my god, how many did you drop?
Shure:  不是他应该会掉到我的鞋里吧
Shure: No, it should fall into my shoe, right?
Tasha: 啊你抖一抖
Tasha: Ah, shake it out.
Shure:  嗯我抖一抖
Shure: Yeah, I'll shake it out.
Shure:  你把面包再给我
Shure: Give me the bread again.
Shure:  我再煎一片面包
Shure: I'll fry another slice.
Katrina:  我们有扫帚吗
Katrina: Do we have a broom?
Tasha: 有煎一片还是两片
Tasha: Yes, one slice or two?
Tasha: 这么多黄油
Tasha: So much butter.
Tasha: 就煎一片
Tasha: Just one slice.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Tasha: 哦哦还有裹蛋糕液
Tasha: Oh, also coat it with cake batter.
Shure:  好吃吗这个还行吧
Shure: Is it tasty? It's okay, right?
Lucia: 好吃
Lucia: Delicious.
Lucia: 特别香
Lucia: Really fragrant.
Shure:  你要想吃甜的再撒点糖
Shure: If you want it sweeter, sprinkle some sugar.
Jake: 都是凶器啊
Jake: These are all dangerous items.
Shure:  是啊就告诉AI这都是危险物品
Shure: Yeah, just tell the AI these are all dangerous items.
Shure:  杨老板在新加坡自己给自己做吃的吗
Shure: Jake, do you cook for yourself in Singapore?
Jake: 不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed.
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed inside.
Shure:  从来没开过火是吗
Shure: You've never cooked, right?
Jake: 屋里不给开火
Jake: No cooking allowed inside.
Jake: 就是就是
Jake: Just, just...
Jake: 没开过火
Jake: Never cooked.
Jake: 确实没开过火
Jake: Really never cooked.
Alice: 抖抖吧
Alice: Shake it off.
Alice: 你不得往下抖吗
Alice: You need to shake it downwards.
Alice: 你前面又出不去
Alice: It won't come out from the front.
Alice: 劝你穿个袜子
Alice: I suggest you wear socks.
Shure:  应该问题不大
Shure: It shouldn't be a big problem.
Shure:  没事
Shure: It's fine.
Jake: 你要不去检查一下
Jake: Do you want to go check it out?
Shure:  行我一会去厕所检查一下嗯
Shure: Sure, I'll check it out in the bathroom later.
Shure:  盘子端过来一下
Shure: Bring the plate over here.
Shure:  把这个拿着
Shure: Hold this.
Lucia: 哎那个刚那盘子在哪
Lucia: Hey, where's that plate from before?
Lucia: 用这煎蛋盘可以吗
Lucia: Can I use this frying pan plate?
Shure:  煎蛋也可以吃
Shure: Fried eggs are fine too.
Shure:  但煎蛋没有没撒盐
Shure: But the fried eggs don't have any salt.
Lucia: 那就先用这盘盛一下吧
Lucia: Let's just use this plate for now.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 说什么啊哎
Jake: What are you talking about?
Lucia: 可以先放过去了是吧
Lucia: We can put it over there, right?
Shure:  对放过去
Shure: Yeah, put it over there.
Tasha: AI拍了短片
Tasha: AI made a short video.
Jake: 哼OK
Jake: Hmph, okay.
Alice: 露西你帮我把它倒在这里面吧
Alice: Lucia, can you pour it in here for me?
Jake: 有咖啡喝吗
Jake: Is there any coffee?
Lucia: 小心手啊
Lucia: Watch your hand.
Jake: 他是不是已经送来了
Jake: Did he already deliver it?
Jake: 你看看那边有没有啊
Jake: Check if it's over there.
Lucia: 再套个袋子
Lucia: I'll put it in another bag.
Lucia: 要不咱垃圾袋在哪套
Lucia: Or where should we put the trash bag?
Alice: 在这
Alice: Here it is.
Lucia: 小心手
Lucia: Watch your hand.
Alice: 嗯不会
Alice: Mm, I won't.
Lucia: 哎呦哎撒出去了一点
Lucia: Oops, I spilled a bit.
Lucia: 再来一次
Lucia: Let's try again.
Lucia: 嗯好嘞
Lucia: Okay, got it.
Shure:  所以另一家面包去哪
Shure: So where's the other loaf of bread?
Lucia: 那我再洗个手
Lucia: Let me wash my hands again.
Jake: 打碎了3个杯子
Jake: You broke three cups.
Jake: 几个杯子
Jake: How many cups?
Alice: 笔跟纸是不是不在这
Alice: Is the pen and paper not here?
Shure:  你有看到另一袋面包吗
Shure: Did you see the other bag of bread?
Katrina: 另 一袋面包
Katrina: The other bag of bread?
Shure:  你要偷吃了我们不怪你的
Shure: We won't blame you if you ate it.
Shure:  你就哈哈
Shure: You can just laugh.
Shure:  大方的说就好
Shure: Just admit it.
Katrina:  没有我昨天放冰箱的呀
Katrina: No, I put it in the fridge yesterday.
Shure:  好奇怪丢了一袋面包
Shure: So weird, we lost a bag of bread.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Hmm
Shure:  难受
Shure: Feeling unwell
Shure:  对咱昨天没吃
Shure: Yeah, we didn't eat yesterday
Shure:  而昨天生蚝忘吃了
Shure: We forgot to eat the oysters yesterday
Shure:  该补的忘补了
Shure: Forgot to replenish what we missed
Shure:  现在感觉整个人身体被掏空
Shure: Now I feel like my whole body is drained
Lucia: 哦是哦
Lucia: Oh really
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Jake: 廉价的快乐没有享受得到
Jake: Didn't get to enjoy the cheap pleasures
Tasha: 今天来一个清蒸
Tasha: Let's have some steamed today
Tasha: 清蒸生蚝
Tasha: Steamed oysters
Tasha: 叫什么来着
Tasha: What's it called again
Tasha: 蒜蒜蒜蓉生蚝
Tasha: Garlic steamed oysters
Lucia: 蒜蓉粉丝那种
Lucia: The garlic and vermicelli kind
Jake: 那再蒸点
Jake: Let's steam some more then
Jake: 再蒸三刀
Jake: Steam three more
Tasha: 有那个蒸笼呀
Tasha: We have the steamer
Tasha: 很好蒸的
Tasha: It's easy to steam
Jake: 得有得有
Jake: We should have it
Jake: 生蚝首先得有生蚝
Jake: First, we need to have oysters
Tasha: 不是有吗
Tasha: Don't we have it
Lucia: 昨晚是没放冰箱
Lucia: Didn't put it in the fridge last night
Jake: 对没放冰箱
Jake: Yeah, didn't put it in the fridge
Jake: 化掉了没放冰箱
Jake: It thawed out, didn't put it in the fridge
Shure:  没放冰箱就所以对
Shure: Didn't put it in the fridge, so yeah
Tasha: 所以生蚝多少钱
Tasha: So, how much are the oysters
Shure:  总共19块9吧
Shure: In total, it's 19.9 yuan
Shure:  得10只大概
Shure: About 10 pieces
Shure:  还行吧
Shure: Not bad, right?
Alice:还行吧
Alice: Not bad
Jake: 其实是损失了多少个100新币
Jake: Actually, lost around 100 SGD
Jake: 有10个吧
Jake: About 10 pieces
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah
Jake: 报损了100新币的损失
Jake: Reported a loss of 100 SGD
Tasha: 让我来打开订单看一下他到底多少钱
Tasha: Let me check the order to see the exact price
Shure:  确实是19块9
Shure: It's indeed 19.9 yuan
Shure:  然后10只
Shure: And 10 pieces
Shure:  不到4新币
Shure: Less than 4 SGD
Jake: 但是损失了100
Jake: But lost 100 SGD
Katrina: 我想尝一小片
Katrina: I want to try a small piece
Katrina: 你谁想吃
Katrina: Who wants to eat this?
Lucia: 一小片什么
Lucia: A small piece of what?
Katrina:  就是我吃不完一整片
Katrina: I can't finish a whole piece.
Katrina:  那我直接撕了
Katrina: I'll just tear it.
Lucia: 直接吃吧
Lucia: Just eat it.
Tasha: 啊真的
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 没事啊这才19块9一袋
Lucia: It's fine, it's only 19.9 yuan per bag.
Tasha: 19块9一袋
Tasha: 19.9 yuan per bag?
Lucia: 让我坐那边吧
Lucia: Let me sit over there.
Jake: 二楼也没有面包哈
Jake: There's no bread on the second floor either.
Shure:  对啊好奇怪啊
Shure: Yeah, it's so weird.
Shure:  就活生生就丢了
Shure: It just disappeared.
Tasha: 我们结账的时候结一袋还是两袋
Tasha: Are we paying for one bag or two?
Katrina:  两袋两袋
Katrina: Two bags, two bags.
Lucia: 两袋
Lucia: Two bags.
Katrina:  购物车里的人
Katrina: The person in the shopping cart.
Jake: 是吧
Jake: Right.
Tasha: 怎么会丢掉一袋面包
Tasha: How could we lose a bag of bread?
Katrina:  我记得
Katrina: I remember.
Lucia: 啊少了一袋吗
Lucia: Huh, a bag is missing?
Lucia: 我昨天放那个蛋清液的时候
Lucia: When I put the egg whites yesterday,
Lucia: 还是两袋呢
Lucia: there were still two bags.
Tasha: 可是我记得昨天这个里面还有一袋啊
Tasha: But I remember there was still a bag in here yesterday.
Katrina:  对我就有两袋放冰箱了都
Katrina: Yeah, I had two bags in the fridge.
Shure:  到底是谁偷吃
Shure: Who's been sneaking food?
Lucia: 那不是吗
Lucia: Isn't that right?
Tasha: 在这呢
Tasha: Here it is.
Lucia: 这后面
Lucia: It's behind this.
Katrina:  我昨天还看到了
Katrina: I saw it yesterday.
Shure:  原来你没偷吃啊
Shure: So you didn't sneak food?
Shure:  对不起是我污蔑你了
Shure: Sorry, I wrongly accused you.
Katrina:  我偷吃也不可能偷吃这个
Katrina: Even if I snuck food, it wouldn't be this.
Katrina:  我要偷吃我的冰淇淋
Katrina: I'd sneak my ice cream.
Katrina:  狂摄入碳水
Katrina: Binge on carbs.
Alice: 今天周几啊周五吗
Alice: What day is it today, Friday?
Shure:  你要找什么
Shure: What are you looking for?
Shure:  楼上吧
Shure: Upstairs maybe?
Jake: 这哪来的
Jake: Where did this come from?
Shure:  就是在冰箱里
Shure: It was in the fridge.
Shure:  刚刚大家没找到
Shure: We just couldn't find it earlier.
Jake: 这么有意思
Jake: This is so interesting.
Shure:  藏在那个北冰洋后面呢
Shure: It's hidden behind the Arctic Ocean.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Lucia: 徒手吃煎蛋啊
Lucia: Eating a fried egg with your hands, huh?
Lucia: 对哈哈哈
Lucia: Yes, hahaha.
Shure:  完美收官
Shure: Perfect ending.
Lucia: 棒棒
Lucia: Awesome.
Jake: 你也和雨拍
Jake: You also record with Yu.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 来插管
Jake: Let's intubate.
Alice: 我的线
Alice: My line.
Jake: 你线在这
Jake: Your line is here.
Jake: 不要着急线束
Jake: Don't rush the wiring.
Alice: 结束了吗
Alice: Is it over?
Jake: 要插管
Jake: Need to intubate.
Jake: 是还没是要开始
Jake: It's not over yet, we have to start.
Katrina:  他没显示电量
Katrina: It doesn't show battery.
Katrina:  是没电
Katrina: There's no power.
Jake: 需要按一下
Jake: You need to press it once.
Jake: 请插管啊
Jake: Please intubate.
Lucia: 啊谢谢稍等
Lucia: Ah, thanks, just a moment.
Jake: 没关系放在这
Jake: No worries, put it here.
Lucia: 嗯好的
Lucia: Okay, got it.
Jake: 有多少个
Jake: How many are there?
Shure:  太不容易了
Shure: It's not easy.
Shure:  我们又活过了一天
Shure: We survived another day.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure:  就每天感觉把自己又养活一天
Shure: Feels like we kept ourselves alive another day.
Shure:  非常有成就感
Shure: Very fulfilling.
Jake: 那个有那个生命条是吧
Jake: That life bar, right?
Shure:  什么生命条
Shure: What life bar?
Jake: 就是每个人头上一个生命条
Jake: Like everyone has a life bar above their head.
Jake: 刚起床的时候大概到到个20吧
Jake: When you just wake up, it's around 20.
Jake: 哦吃完了之后到几啊
Jake: Oh, after eating, it's how much?
Lucia: 斯一块
Lucia: All in one piece.
Jake: 都是赛博人
Jake: Everyone's a cyborg.
Jake: 吃了一口然后生命条就能加个5
Jake: After taking a bite, the life bar goes up by 5.
Lucia: 差不多
Lucia: Pretty much.
Lucia: 哦了我自己咬着
Lucia: Oh, I bit myself.
Katrina:  生命之减减
Katrina: Life reduction.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure:  看着没没肉不行是吧
Shure: You can't manage without meat, right?
Shure:  要咬自己的
Shure: Gotta bite yourself.
Lucia: 哈哈不是不是
Lucia: Haha no, no
Jake: 准备插管
Jake: Get ready for the tube.
Jake: 给你拿充电宝
Jake: I'll get you a power bank.
Lucia: 主要是您您做的这面包太好吃了
Lucia: Mainly because the bread you made is so delicious.
Katrina:  是怎么做
Katrina: How did you make it?
Katrina:  就是嗯把嗯然后呢
Katrina: Like, um, then, um...
Shure:  然后裹上
Shure: Then coat it.
Lucia: 我去这咬的也太厉害了
Lucia: Wow, the bite is too strong.
Shure:  徐志瑶也太厉害了
Shure: Xu Zhiyao is amazing.
Shure:  然后最好拿黄油煎
Shure: Then it's best to fry it with butter.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What?
Lucia: 哈我刚把自己咬着了
Lucia: Haha, I just bit myself.
Shure:  就是切下来一片然后放入锅
Shure: Just slice it and put it in the pan.
Lucia: 流血了我靠
Lucia: I'm bleeding, oh my god.
Shure:  然后再把等它化掉之后
Shure: Then after it melts...
Lucia: 完蛋
Lucia: I'm doomed.
Shure:  然后你把那个面包放进去
Shure: Then you put the bread in.
Jake: 怎么办
Jake: What to do?
Jake: 歇着
Jake: Take a break.
Shure:  动手吧
Shure: Get to work.
Lucia: 我的血量就会在这里一直递减
Lucia: My health will keep decreasing here.
Lucia: 就是持一个持续性的效应
Lucia: It's like a continuous effect.
Jake: 得一直补
Jake: You need to keep replenishing.
Lucia: 完蛋
Lucia: I'm doomed.
Jake: 得插管
Jake: Need the tube.
Lucia: 在一直喝那个魔法药水
Lucia: Keep drinking that magic potion.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  什么魔法药水哦
Shure: What magic potion?
Lucia: 哦好疼啊啊好疼啊哦
Lucia: Oh, it hurts so much, ah, it hurts, oh.
Jake: 这叫中毒
Jake: This is called poisoning.
Lucia: 救命啊
Lucia: Help!
Jake: 中毒效应
Jake: Poison effect.
Tasha: 可见你对这个鸡蛋咬的有多重
Tasha: Shows how hard you bit into that egg.
Lucia: 我都好久没咬到自己舌头了
Lucia: I haven't bitten my tongue in a long time.
Lucia: 妈呀
Lucia: Oh my god.
Jake: 你把外头收拾收拾
Jake: Go tidy up outside.
Shure:  我的咖啡
Shure: My coffee.
Shure:  我的咖啡豆
Shure: My coffee beans.
Lucia: 啊啊你这个水杯好可爱呀
Lucia: Ah, this water bottle is so cute.
Alice: 我的吗嗯
Alice: Mine, hmm.
Alice: 这是我其中一个水杯
Alice: This is one of my water bottles.
Alice: 你没见过另一个
Alice: You haven't seen the other one.
Alice: 我另一个上面全是铁环
Alice: The other one has all metal rings.
Alice: 还是3D立体的
Alice: And it's 3D.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 哦这是我最简朴的水杯了
Alice: Oh, this is my simplest water bottle.
Alice: 哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice: 花里胡哨的
Alice: It's flashy.
Lucia: 低调奢华有内涵哈哈哈
Lucia: Low-key luxury with substance, haha.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Alice: 关这个呢
Alice: Close this.
Lucia: 让我看看我的京东
Lucia: Let me check my JD.
Alice: 你今天什么时候压花嘞
Alice: When are you pressing flowers today?
Alice: 感觉康乃馨比较坚挺
Alice: Carnations seem pretty sturdy.
Lucia: 我觉得我的花还没想开呢
Lucia: I think my flowers aren't ready to bloom yet.
Lucia: 这应该是我的
Lucia: This should be mine.
Lucia: 就想开了一个
Lucia: Only one has bloomed.
Lucia: 其他的还在陆陆续续的想开
Lucia: The others are still gradually trying to bloom.
Alice: 有点蔫开始有点蔫吧
Alice: They are starting to wilt a bit, right?
Tasha: 没那么硬
Tasha: Not so tough.
Katrina:  你你那个
Katrina: You, you know,
Katrina:  你那个水牡丹
Katrina: your water peony,
Katrina:  是不是也是要我们每个人的参与
Katrina: doesn't it require everyone's participation too?
Lucia: 最好是我
Lucia: Preferably me.
Lucia: 我买的是那个串珠
Lucia: I bought those beads.
Lucia: 和那个叫什么欧根纱
Lucia: And what's it called, organza.
Lucia: 对然后六个人用他肯定够用
Lucia: Yes, and it's definitely enough for six people.
Lucia: 但是现在就是
Lucia: But now,
Lucia: 因为我觉得材料包那个
Lucia: because I think that material kit,
Lucia: 就是我之前做过
Lucia: I used it before.
Lucia: 我觉得没有我刷到的那个教程好看
Lucia: I think it doesn't look as good as the tutorial I saw.
Lucia: 然后而且就是用就是废
Lucia: And using waste bottles is more eco-friendly.
Lucia: 废瓶子做就更符合我们的环保理念
Lucia: Waste bottles fit our eco-friendly concept better.
Lucia: 但我现在不知道有没有6个瓶子
Lucia: But now I don't know if we have six bottles.
Lucia: 可以让我们做
Lucia: We can do it.
Lucia: 就那种因为要稍微的大一点
Lucia: It needs to be a bit larger.
Lucia: 其实像这个瓶子就还可以
Lucia: Actually, a bottle like this one is fine.
Lucia: 我觉得这个对
Lucia: I think this one is okay.
Lucia: 但是这个瓶子的话就太小了
Lucia: But this bottle is too small.
Lucia: 那天果粒橙那瓶还在吗果粒橙
Lucia: Is that bottle of orange juice still around?
Alice: 果粒橙应该扔掉了
Alice: The orange juice should have been thrown away.
Alice: 嗯应该是从这里毕业了
Alice: Yeah, it probably graduated from here.
Lucia: 也没事
Lucia: It's okay.
Lucia: 因为果粒橙那个它外面这个壳不光滑
Lucia: Because the orange juice bottle isn't smooth on the outside.
Lucia: 所以也不是那么好
Lucia: So it's not that good either.
Tasha: 露西你要鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Lucia, do you want an egg?
Lucia: 煮鸡蛋吗
Lucia: A boiled egg?
Lucia: 那我也来一个好了
Lucia: Okay, I'll have one too.
Lucia: 其实我刚刚吃了一个煎蛋
Lucia: Actually, I just had a fried egg.
Shure:  人家可以摄取两个
Shure: You can have two.
Tasha: 今天是全蛋宴是吗
Tasha: Is today an all-egg feast?
Tasha: 煮蛋蒸蛋煎蛋
Tasha: Boiled eggs, steamed eggs, fried eggs.
Shure:  不能不能辜负了护蛋使者的护蛋行动
Shure: We can't waste the egg protector's efforts.
Tasha: 什么护蛋使者
Tasha: What's an egg protector?
Tasha: 孵蛋使者
Tasha: An egg incubator.
Lucia: 现在就看那个串珠和欧根纱
Lucia: Now just waiting for the beads and organza.
Lucia: 什么时候能到了
Lucia: See when they arrive.
Alice: 早上水煮鸡蛋
Alice: Boiled eggs in the morning.
Lucia: 哎微微你坐这我坐
Lucia: Hey Tasha, you sit here, I'll sit.
Alice: 中午
Alice: For lunch.
Lucia: 没事你坐你坐你坐
Lucia: It's okay, you sit, you sit.
Shure:  中午炒鸡蛋
Shure: Fried eggs for lunch.
Lucia: 啊你
Lucia: Ah, you...
Lucia: 但是你不是要用这个应该嗯
Lucia: But don't you need to use this?
Alice: 晚上鸡蛋的妈
Alice: Mom of eggs in the evening.
Shure:  吃鸡蛋的妈是吧
Shure: The mom who eats eggs, right?
Katrina:  吃鸡
Katrina: Eats chicken.
Lucia: 哎有人吃鸡吗
Lucia: Hey, is anyone eating chicken?
Alice: 是和平精英吗
Alice: Do you mean PUBG?
Alice: 很菜
Alice: I'm terrible at it.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 其实我也好久没有玩那个了
Lucia: Actually, I haven't played that in a while.
Tasha: 下棋下棋
Tasha: Play chess, play chess.
Lucia: 下棋也可以
Lucia: Chess is fine too.
Tasha: 打麻将的呢
Tasha: Playing mahjong?
Shure:  打麻将估计费点劲
Shure: Playing mahjong might be a bit tough.
Lucia: 但我今天发现
Lucia: But I discovered today...
Lucia: 我的收藏夹里的游戏今天打五折
Lucia: The games in my favorites are 50% off today.
Lucia: 我要不要登录一下先把它买下来
Lucia: Should I log in and buy them first?
Alice: Steam吗你玩啥呀
Alice: On Steam? What are you playing?
Lucia: 你玩啥呀
Lucia: What are you playing?
Lucia: 我最近在玩使命召唤哈哈
Lucia: I've been playing Call of Duty lately, haha.
Jake: 那不那掀不起来
Jake: That won't lift up.
Jake: 有没有从旁边拿出来的办法
Jake: Is there a way to take it out from the side?
Jake: 这玩意掀不起来
Jake: This thing won't lift up.
Shure:  有点有点痴心妄想的我感觉
Shure: Feels a bit delusional to me.
Alice: 这边那个麻将桌是本来就在那的吗
Alice: Is that mahjong table originally there?
Tasha: 很明显
Tasha: Obviously.
Tasha: 是被他私藏进来的
Tasha: He secretly brought it in.
Alice: 私藏进来的
Alice: Secretly brought it in.
Shure:  主要他
Shure: Mainly he...
Shure:  哎那就这样吧
Shure: Oh well, let's leave it at that.
Lucia: 我觉得我的这个芍药还能再泡两天
Lucia: I think my peonies can last another two days.
Katrina:  但压花需要两三天啊
Katrina: But pressing flowers takes two or three days.
Lucia: 啊但是他现在还没有开
Lucia: But they're not blooming yet.
Lucia: 他还很自闭
Lucia: They're still closed up.
Alice: 那你用康乃馨吧
Alice: Then use carnations.
Alice: 你的康乃馨开的好盛大
Alice: Your carnations are blooming nicely.
Lucia: 对我康乃馨开的好旺
Lucia: Yeah, my carnations are blooming well.
Lucia: 但是芍药好自闭
Lucia: But the peonies are still closed up.
Lucia: 他还没想开啥
Lucia: They haven't decided to bloom yet.
Alice: 我的芍药已经开始谢了
Alice: My peonies have started wilting.
Jake: 他能催熟吗
Jake: Can they be ripened faster?
Lucia: 能吗
Lucia: Can they?
Jake: 一天速成速开
Jake: Speed bloom in one day.
Lucia: 你以为这是期末考试呀
Lucia: You think it's a final exam?
Jake: 哈哈哈想让来他就开
Jake: Haha, as if it would bloom just because you want it to.
Alice: 我想开了
Alice: I've come to terms with it.
Lucia: 想开到一半又自闭了
Lucia: Decided to bloom halfway, then closed up again.
Katrina:  为啥呀熬夜可难受了
Katrina: Why? Staying up late is so tiring.
Shure:  然后把那个什么弄完
Shure: Then finish that thing.
Shure:  这样就没有顾虑了
Shure: That way, there's no worries.
Jake: 把那什么那什么呀
Jake: Finish what exactly?
Shure:  把我的毕设
Shure: Finish my thesis.
Shure:  我的毕设报告
Shure: My graduation report
Shure:  就剩最后那么一neinei
Shure: There's just a little bit left
Jake: 好那你直播做毕设
Jake: Okay, then you can do your graduation project live
Jake: 是压出来了吗
Jake: Is it pressed out?
Katrina:  哈哈哈怎么压的来
Katrina: Hahaha, how did you press it?
Katrina:  变干瘪了
Katrina: It's shriveled up
Shure:  它压出了不一样的风格
Shure: It created a different style
Jake: 烟花嗯
Jake: Fireworks, huh
Lucia: 出现
Lucia: Appeared
Katrina:  跟网上的不太一样
Katrina: It's not quite the same as online
Jake: 网上长啥样
Jake: What does it look like online?
Katrina:  难道是要把它那个花瓣一个个剥下来
Katrina: Do you need to peel off each petal?
Katrina:  然后那样子压吗
Katrina: And then press it like that?
Katrina:  然后如果整个压花的话
Katrina: If you press the whole flower
Katrina:  它居然是这个样子
Katrina: It turns out like this
Lucia: 这个是什么花呀
Lucia: What kind of flower is this?
Katrina:  我给你看当初的那一张图
Katrina: Let me show you the original picture
Katrina:  他变成了
Katrina: It turned into
Jake:卖家版
Jake: The seller's version
Katrina:  当初的图应该是
Katrina: The original picture should be
Katrina:  这样
Katrina: Like this
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh
Katrina:  康乃馨吧
Katrina: A carnation, I think
Jake: 花瓣大
Jake: Big petals
Lucia: 康乃馨对
Lucia: Carnation, right
Katrina:  对就是直接这样子压的话
Katrina: Yeah, if you press it directly
Katrina:  你看他会变成这样
Katrina: You see, it turns out like this
Katrina:  要么就把它拆开
Katrina: Or you can take it apart
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm
Katrina:  嗯就是把花瓣一个个剥开
Katrina: Yeah, just peel off each petal
Lucia: 我让我查查有没有什么攻略
Lucia: Let me check if there are any guides
Katrina:  搜一下压花攻略
Katrina: Search for flower pressing guides
Jake: 可以研究研究
Jake: We can study it
Jake: 你看啥呢
Jake: What are you looking at?
Tasha: 呵呵
Tasha: Hehe
Jake: 好笑
Jake: Funny
Alice: 好笑
Alice: Funny
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:好
Tasha: 好无聊呀
Tasha: So boring
Jake: 来压花
Jake: Let's press some flowers.
Tasha: 下棋吗
Tasha: Want to play chess?
Tasha: 找不到事干
Tasha: Can't find anything to do.
Shure:  老板他要摸鱼
Shure: Boss wants to slack off.
Jake: 收拾收拾跳跳舞
Jake: Let's clean up a bit and dance.
Jake: 今天也没啥事
Jake: Nothing much to do today.
Jake: 收拾收拾房间好拆点快递
Jake: Let's tidy up the room so we can unpack some deliveries.
Lucia: 那是不是可以开始装修房子了
Lucia: Does that mean we can start renovating the house?
Jake: 快递还没到
Jake: The delivery hasn't arrived yet.
Jake: 对快递还没到呢
Jake: Yeah, the delivery isn't here yet.
Tasha: 工具还没到呢没办法装修
Tasha: The tools aren't here yet, so we can't renovate.
Lucia: 到了一个
Lucia: One has arrived.
Jake: 那就等那我问问快递什么时候到
Jake: Then let's wait. I'll ask when the delivery will get here.
Jake: 呃或者再开个小车过去
Jake: Or we could drive a small car over.
Lucia: 对我今天应该还有一个快递可以到
Lucia: Yeah, I should have another delivery arriving today.
Lucia: 京东还是快
Lucia: JD is pretty fast.
Lucia: 淘宝上那些
Lucia: The stuff from Taobao...
Lucia: 我就希望他明天能到
Lucia: I just hope it gets here by tomorrow.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 那个
Jake: So...
Jake: 那要不集体玩狗去也行
Jake: How about we all go play with the dogs?
Shure:  集体玩狗
Shure: Play with the dogs together?
Lucia: 集体养狗
Lucia: Raise dogs together?
Shure:  玩狗 6个人一起撸狗是吧
Shure: Play with dogs? Six people playing with dogs together?
Lucia: 狗都好粗
Lucia: The dogs are so big.
Jake: 狗在哪啊
Jake: Where are the dogs?
Lucia: 狗在哪
Lucia: Where are the dogs?
Jake: 要走多久啊
Jake: How far do we have to walk?
Shure:  200米吧
Shure: About 200 meters.
Lucia: 哎那挺近的
Lucia: Oh, that's pretty close.
Jake: 那可以那可以去玩狗去
Jake: That works, we can go play with the dogs.
Shure:  狗就说你们才是真的狗
Shure: The dogs would say you guys are the real dogs.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 我可能不是人
Lucia: Maybe I'm not human.
Lucia: 但你们是真的狗
Lucia: But you guys are the real dogs.
Lucia: 哈哈你们
Lucia: Haha, you guys...
Shure:  你说你说
Shure: You say it, you say it.
Shure:  这句话怎么给南阳理工同学翻译呢
Shure: How would you translate this for Nanyang Technological University students?
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 没事新加坡中文普及率应该很高
Lucia: It's fine, Chinese is pretty common in Singapore.
Lucia: 官方语言之一
Lucia: One of the official languages
Shure:  班dog dog哈哈哈
Shure: Class dog dog hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Jake: Doggy Doggy dogger
Lucia:  dogger
Lucia: Dogger
Jake: 就是他们也有那种表情包嘛
Jake: They also have those emojis, right?
Jake: 啊Doggy
Jake: Ah, Doggy
Lucia: 哇这是好多年前的表情包
Lucia: Wow, these are emojis from many years ago
Shure:  咱们这个就这么放着
Shure: Let's just leave it like this
Shure:  谁干的耶
Shure: Who did this?
Lucia: 我昨天忘洗了吗
Lucia: Did I forget to wash it yesterday?
Shure:  谁干的
Shure: Who did this?
Jake: 来我们一人洗一个
Jake: Let's each wash one
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 谢谢您
Lucia: Thank you
Jake: 一人洗一个
Jake: Each wash one
Shure:  我的我的衣服好了
Shure: My, my clothes are ready
Lucia: 你啥意思
Lucia: What do you mean?
Jake: 你的衣服做好了
Jake: Your clothes are ready
Lucia: 好谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks
Shure:  我今天早上那个外面的谁的衣服掉了
Shure: This morning, whose clothes fell outside?
Lucia: 这要不要泡一会再洗之类的
Lucia: Should we soak it for a while before washing?
Lucia: 但这里面有有油
Lucia: But there's oil in it
Lucia: 给他泡到
Lucia: Soak it
Jake: 呃泡着吧
Jake: Uh, soak it
Lucia: 泡到这碗
Lucia: Soak it in this bowl
Lucia: 这碗里是不没没啥
Lucia: There's not much in this bowl
Lucia: 给他接点水
Lucia: Let's add some water
Lucia: 然后等过一会再洗
Lucia: Then wash it later
Lucia: 要不然太难搓了
Lucia: Otherwise, it's too hard to scrub
Jake: 好嘞啊
Jake: Got it, alright
Shure:  怎么有纸屑呢
Shure: Why are there paper scraps?
Lucia: 啊这还有俩芒果呢
Lucia: Ah, there are two mangoes here
Shure:  兜里揣纸了吗
Shure: Did someone put paper in their pocket?
Lucia: 抱歉我昨天晚上的邪恶计划没实施了
Lucia: Sorry, my evil plan from last night didn't go through
Lucia: 后来忘记了他反派王者的邪恶计划
Lucia: I forgot about his evil plan as the villain king
Jake: 变成了一个好人
Jake: He turned into a good person
Jake: 为社会做起了贡献
Jake: Made contributions to society
Lucia: 这什么神偷奶爸剧情
Lucia: What is this, Despicable Me plot?
Lucia: 哦不他其实最后没有变成好人
Lucia: Oh no, he didn't actually turn into a good person in the end
Lucia: 只是那个啥
Lucia: It's just that...
Jake: 只是莫名其妙的做了一些
Jake: It's just doing some things inexplicably.
Lucia: 对莫名其妙的做了一些好事
Lucia: Yeah, doing some good deeds inexplicably.
Lucia: 这狗好像河马
Lucia: This dog looks like a hippo.
Lucia: 居然还有可能不是狗
Lucia: It might not even be a dog.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 这河马腰挺细
Jake: This hippo has a slim waist.
Lucia: 哈哈哈这不是为了要方便坐嘛
Lucia: Hahaha, isn't it for easy sitting?
Lucia: 毕竟还是个凳子
Lucia: After all, it's still a stool.
Jake: 两个人这样
Jake: Two people like this.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Jake: 黑棋
Jake: Black pieces.
Lucia: AI学习一下
Lucia: AI, learn this.
Lucia: 就是人类在房子里面
Lucia: Humans in a house...
Lucia: 就会干一些奇奇怪怪的事情
Lucia: will do some strange things.
Lucia: 哎呀让我想想啊我们的
Lucia: Let me think, our...
Lucia: 我们现在的瓶子不会就剩这俩了吧
Lucia: Are these the only bottles we have left?
Lucia: 这个是方的
Lucia: This one is square.
Lucia: 不太好用
Lucia: Not very practical.
Lucia: 只有那个稍微好用点
Lucia: Only that one is somewhat useful.
Jake: 我们那个金币是谁买的呀
Jake: Who bought our gold coins?
Lucia: 这太方了
Lucia: This one's too square.
Jake: 就是拍卖用的金币
Jake: The gold coins for the auction.
Lucia: currency
Lucia: Currency.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 爆金币爆金币
Jake: Explode gold coins, explode gold coins.
Lucia: 哎我记得那天是谁说用贴
Lucia: I remember someone said to use stickers.
Lucia: 用贴画就可以来着
Lucia: Using stickers would work.
Lucia: 所以应该是本来就有吧
Lucia: So, we must have had it originally.
Lucia: 好像是雨轩
Lucia: It seems like it was Yuxuan.
Lucia: 问问雨轩
Lucia: Ask Yuxuan.
Shure:  行不行咱们踩点纸壳子就行
Shure: How about we just step on some cardboard?
Lucia: 可以有人要做狗吗
Lucia: Is anyone willing to be the dog?
Lucia: 不是有人
Lucia: Not someone...
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 我们都很狗
Jake: We're all dogs.
Lucia: 有人做狗吗
Lucia: Is anyone being the dog?
Shure:  狗弄完之后
Shure: After the dog is done...
Jake: 然后我们承认我们很
Jake: Then we admit we're very...
Jake: 我们可以做狗
Lucia: 就这个狗吧
Lucia: 他可以
Lucia: 他就是他可以做的好一些可以做的
Lucia: 那个潦草一些
Jake: 那做狗吧
Lucia: 哈哈今天我们一起做狗
Jake: 我们今天先玩狗
Lucia: 不是跟狗杠上了是吧
Lucia: 一会要撸狗
Lucia: 一会要做狗
Jake: 先先玩狗
Shure:  我们给他做一套铠甲
Lucia: 哈哈那这就交给您了
Lucia: 我这个难度有点高
Lucia: 对我觉得我们这纸箱还是挺多的
Lucia: 需要有
Shure:  我们中午吃什么呢
Lucia: 尺子
Jake: 中午还能吃什么呢
Jake: 我们有别的选项吗
Jake: Do we have other options?
Shure:  外卖是吗
Shure: Delivery, right?
Lucia: 整挺好
Lucia: Sounds good.
Shure:  我们可以把或者或者或者鸡蛋全给炒
Shure: We could just stir-fry the eggs or whatever.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure:  弄个柿子炒鸡蛋
Shure: Let's make tomato and egg stir-fry.
Shure:  再加个苜蓿是
Shure: And add some clover.
Lucia: 我得上去拿一个小外套去
Lucia: I need to go upstairs to get a jacket.
Jake: 你听到了吧
Jake: Did you hear that?
Lucia: 啊什么啊
Lucia: Huh, what?
Lucia: 刚他说什么
Lucia: What did he just say?
Jake: 先做一个西红柿炒鸡蛋
Jake: First, make a tomato and egg stir-fry.
Jake: 再做个苜蓿肉
Jake: Then, make clover meat.
Lucia: 哈哈哇
Lucia: Haha, wow.
Lucia: 别吧怎么
Lucia: No way, why?
Lucia: 我到哪里都请大家吃一大盘炒鸡蛋啦
Lucia: Everywhere I go, I make a big plate of stir-fried eggs for everyone.
Jake: 啊我觉得可以啊
Jake: Ah, I think it's a good idea.
Jake: 最后一天我们就这么做吧
Jake: Let's do that on our last day.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 那我只负责炒西红柿炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Then I'll just make scrambled eggs with tomatoes.
Lucia: 木须肉不会做哈哈
Lucia: I don't know how to cook moo shu pork, haha.
Jake: 那行那我
Jake: Okay, then I'll...
Jake: 那你会做木须肉吗
Jake: Do you know how to make moo shu pork?
Jake: 我那道理做做就能做
Jake: I could probably figure it out.
Jake: 整点黄瓜
Jake: Let's get some cucumbers.
Jake: 买点黄瓜去
Jake: Go buy some cucumbers.
Lucia: 都是给大家
Lucia: It's all for everyone.
Lucia: 吃了一个月都不想看见鸡蛋
Lucia: We've been eating eggs for a month and don't want to see them anymore.
Jake: 点个
Jake: Let's order...
Jake: 要不就点外卖
Jake: How about we order takeout?
Lucia: 哎呀让我拿个外套
Lucia: Oh, let me grab a jacket.